The Spider-Man debacle between Sony and Marvel
is getting even stickier.
When it was reported at the end of August
2019 that the two studios had failed to reach
an agreement to renegotiate terms of their
deal that allows Tom Holland's Spider-Man
to be a part of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
...
"Who would do something like that?"
… it seemed that the main reason why things
came crashing down was financial in nature.
Disney, which owns Marvel Studios, was said
to have requested a 50 percent co-financing
stake in the Spider-Man franchise - a dramatic
increase from its previous five percent yield
from day-one profits - which Sony reportedly
denied without countering.
Now, Sony Pictures CEO and chairman Tony Vinciquerra
has revealed another reason for the Spider-Man
split with Marvel — and it doesn't have
anything to do with Disney and Marvel wanting
more money.
During Variety's Entertainment and Technology
summit on September 5th, 2019, Vinciquerra
stated that Marvel Studios president Kevin
Feige had been "stretched incredibly thin"
following Disney's March 2019 acquisition
of 20th Century Fox.
With Feige's workload ramping up to include
discussions and plans for what to do with
the X-Men, the Fantastic Four, Deadpool, and
more, the studio head apparently became overwhelmed
and evidently could no longer properly focus
on keeping Spidey in the MCU.
According to Variety, Vinciquerra pointed
to this as "one of the reasons behind the
breakdown" in conversations about establishing
new terms of the Spider-Man deal.
What certainly didn't cause the divorce was
bad blood, as Vinciquerra affirmed that there
was and is "no ill will" between Sony and
Marvel.
He also had some nice things to say about
working with Feige, who produced both Spider-Man:
Homecoming and Spider-Man: Far From Home,
and noted that neither Sony nor Marvel simply
threw in the towel in regards to the Spider-Man
franchise, saying,
"We had a great run with [Feige] on Spider-Man
movies.
We tried to see if there's a way to work it
out.
The Marvel people are terrific people, we
have great respect for them, but on the other
hand we have some pretty terrific people of
our own.
Kevin didn't do all the work."
Vinciquerra also made a sad confession about
the situation: there's no chance of reconciliation
as of right now.
He explained that, quote, "for the moment,
the door is closed" on having a professional
relationship with Marvel, and the studio is
"not for sale."
Vinciquerra also detailed that Sony has big
plans for Spider-Man without the House of
Mouse involved.
A Spider-Man universe is well underway - set
to include the Tom Hardy-topped Venom and
the upcoming Venom sequel, the Morbius movie
starring Jared Leto, and "five or six" television
series that take place within the Spider-Man
world.
The executive reiterated that Spider-Man is
going to do "just fine" after swinging out
of the MCU, using the Academy Award-winning
animated film Spider-Man: Into the Spider-Verse
as an example of the famous hero thriving
without input from Marvel.
Vinciquerra said,
"Spider-Man was fine before the event movies,
did better with the event movies, and now
that we have our own universe, he will play
off the other characters as well.
I think we're pretty capable of doing what
we have to do here."
Clearly, Sony executives are confident that
Spider-Man will succeed without Feige, Marvel,
and Disney - but what does Spidey himself
think about all this?
Star Tom Holland has remained diplomatic about
the split and hasn't taken sides, stating
that playing Spider-Man has been a dream come
true and that he knows the hero's franchise
is in safe hands with Sony.
"You ready?"
"Yeah."
"You're gonna love this."
What happens next for Spider-Man is slightly
unclear - at least in terms of where his story
will head after Spider-Man: Far From Home,
which tied into several past MCU movies and
included a number of MCU characters - but
we do know that Holland is lined up to appear
in at least two more movies at Sony.
As for Marvel, the studio is gearing up to
enter the fourth phase of the MCU.
Meanwhile, Feige is getting his footing as
the new head of the X-Men film franchise,
which he reportedly plans to reboot with a
brand-new, younger Wolverine.
Here's hoping he can juggle it all and avoid
getting stretched too thin yet again.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
Marvel characters are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.